fire ants are one of nature's most
fearsome cleaning forces a red imported
fire ant army can take down prey much
larger than itself and strip a carcass
clean overnight dozens even hundreds of
fire ants sting in unison and this is
what humans have come to fear the ant
bites down and then stings injecting a
toxic venom that burns like well fire
red imported fire ants were introduced
to the United States in the 1930s
probably stowing away in ballast on a
Brazilian cargo ship now they've spread
across several southern states the ants
build large nests in the soil and once
established are known to devastate the
ecosystem around them they've been known
to radically reduce the number of animal
species in a given area sometimes
eliminating them entirely with the power
of the swarm attack on a beetle not
going well call in reinforcements fire
ants can aggressively take over an area
and spread like wildfire